- You've gotta be (beep) kidding me.
(laughing)
(playful xylophone music)
- I begged my brother for
a Furby, I begged him.
And at the time they were so expensive
and he actually got me one for Christmas.
(playful xylophone music)
- There was this one toy
that was called Sky Dancers,
where you like pulled on this string
and it flew up into the
air because its like,
it had wings on the side that did this.
- I just remember the
Furby being the thing.
I guess it's like the iPhone for adults.
(bright violin music)
(paper ripping)
- Oh my god, you guys!
- (Laughing) Cockadoodledoo?
(paper ripping)
- Oh my god, this is like
the true '90s version.
- This is crazy.
You're so huge!
- Oh.
(Furby squawking)
- Hi, you're so pretty.
You have kind of '80s hair,
but you know, so do I.
- This is kind of cute because
I'm a little bit homesick
and I miss my brother.
So this is heaps cool.
- I had no idea you were going to do this.
(laughing)
- There's something about having a doll,
and especially a life size doll,
like, this is like your friend.
This is the size of me.
(string sliding)
- Oh! (laughing)
(hands patting)
- Oh no! (laughing)
Oh no, come on, play. (laughing)
- (laughing) So much is
flashing back to me right now.
- I feel like six-year-old Daysha.
- When I was a kid, I
definitely had her play like,
different things, like,
I would be like, today
we're adventure Barbie,
we're going on an adventure.
(string buzzing)
- Oh that one's way better.
Okay, we're doing that one again.
(giggling)
- I would do her hair,
'cause I always had this crazy curly hair
and nobody ever had the same hair as me.
- I just wanna,
(playful xylophone music)
(laughing quietly)
and go,
(metal pieces clinking together)
Is this the right way?
I don't even know.
(Furby squawking)
(laughing)
- That's my kid alright.
- You did enable me to do a
lot of fun creative things.
I made up stories for you,
you got me through the
doctors office visits,
so thank you for that, I
appreciate you for that Barbie.
- What was so cool about these was that
it gave you the chance
to look after something
when you weren't allowed pets,
or babies. (laughing)
- Sky Dancers were one of
my favorites because like,
you could like control how high they went.
- My brother and I still
talk about it to this day,
'cause it was such a big
deal for him to spend
that much money on a
Christmas present for me.
- This is insane, this is like
the greatest Christmas surprise.
Gave me back a piece of my childhood.
(slow piano)
- It felt very, magical.
Like Christmas magic, this
felt like Christmas magic.
- I think that I've always
been like an independent person
from the beginning, it's like
nah mom, you don't have
to make food for me,
I got this, I got my Easy-Bake Oven.